wanted to sign your Turkish we have one
last game to talk about today quran
kudasai
hello everyone I'm Yoshiaki poison the
producer of Super Mario
Odysseys a Nintendo switch today we're
going to recap a little of what they've
already shown but also reveals some new
information about the game as well Mario
isn't too happy about Bowser trying to
marry Princess Peach and copy his new
friend from the cat kingdom has a
mission of his own to rescue his sister
tiara and now the hero and his hat must
join forces
[Music]
somehow copy can grant his wearer free
control over his powers so together with
Mario they'll travel the globe and make
good use of Kathy's skills especially
the nude capture ability which allows
Mario to take control of many enemies
animals and objects
[Music]
this globe-trotting adventure will take
them all over the place
new dog city in the Metro Kingdom toast
arena in the sand kingdom Mount vol bono
in the luncheon Kingdom steam gardens in
the wooded Kingdom bonnet n' in the cap
kingdom fossil falls and the cascade
kingdom and today for the first time
we're introducing Chavarria in the snow
kingdom this ice-cold realm will chill
you to the core now take a look at Bubba
Lane in the seaside Kingdom it's a
popular travel destination for many
thanks to its gorgeous crystal clear
waters
apparently the seawater has a refreshing
feels like it's carbonated
[Music]
but we won't spoil them all mario has
even more kingdoms to visit including
tropical islands to get from place to
place
Mario is literally traveling in style
aboard his cap shaped ship The Odyssey
it runs on power moons scattered across
the world by collecting them you can
power up the Odyssey and make it to the
next Kingdom the number of power moons
required to reach a destination is
different for each Kingdom but as you
can see in this list there are even more
power moons than that which should keep
your inner treasure hunter hungry for
more I mean some of these things are
really hidden you may need to acquire
one by solving a puzzle or defeating
enemies they're hiding everywhere so
make sure to explore every corner of the
world using every move at your disposal
if you collect them all something neat
may happen
[Music]
having trouble hunting down power moons
then try talking to talkative or hints
you could also give a few coins to the
hint toad or even tap amiibo with some
help from uncle amiibo to reveal the
power moons location on the map if
you're feeling stuck is worth a shot
globe-trotting does have its benefits
you may find places to play minigames
like a coupe of free running or a jump
rope challenge you'll earn power moons
based on your results and you can check
out the scores and times of other
players the world over if you're
connected online also the game world is
home to a franchise of shops called
crazy cap there you can obtain outfits
and other stuff with the coins you've
collected then customize Mario's look
some outfits are thematically tides of
the kingdom you're in or to a game from
mario storied past so don't be afraid to
play a little dress-up just to suit your
mood match your surroundings or just
because and don't forget to let the
Odyssey in on the action with decorative
stickers and souvenirs from crazy cow
[Music]
there are just so many excuses for a
quick photo op that's where snapshot
mode comes in simply freeze time at any
moment
snap some fun photos of Mario and go for
a close-up you can blur your
surroundings change color schemes you
name it you can even rotate the camera
and nail that vertical photo for your
smartphone you could post it to social
media or use it as wallpaper on your PC
or smartphone for many Mario games are
all about making memories so capture
away
[Music]
we've taken great care in creating these
detailed sandbox environments for you to
explore and make the most of Mario's new
and familiar moves we made sure the game
is chock-full of classic gameplay
elements alongside a wide world of
things you've never done before even the
song that's playing right now is a Mario
series first thanks to its lyrics sung
by the one and only Paulina I hope
you're ready for more surprising new
ideas
[Music]
SuperMario Odyssey landing on Nintendo's
switch October 27th these wedding style
amiibo figures will be available that
same day both individually and as a set
as you can see they'll come in handy
during your adventure and all other
amiibo are supported alongside the game
we're also releasing a special hardware
bundle including a Super Mario Odyssey
software and the themed joy con you see
here along with a carrying case we'll
continue to release more new information
on the official site of Super Mario
Odyssey and on Twitter as we await
Mario's next great journey that's it for
me and from today's Nintendo Direct to
thank me for watching how do you Jose my
stop
[Music]